hallo herzlich willkommen in mainhardt
koch und back welt ich bin sally das ist
er eigentlich weil ihr habt mich
abonniert und ich stehe seit etwa
zweieinhalb jahren vor der kamera für
euch und nehme meine koch und back
videos auf aber gelernt habe ich das
natürlich nicht ich habe nämlich
ursprünglich eigentlich
grundschullehramt studiert grund und
hauptschullehrer amt aber als ich in
elften klasse war
was immer mein traum architektur zu
studieren und zwar habe ich mir den
beruf damals ausgesucht weil ich einfach
was kreatives machen wollte ich habe
nämlich gern gezeichnet und deswegen
wollte ich einfach immer architektur
studieren aber irgendwann habe ich mich
dann doch dagegen entschieden weil mir
das zu einseitig war ich würde was mit
kindern machen und deswegen habe ich auf
mein herz gehört und habe gesagt komm
der lehrerberuf ist auch total kreativ
dass immer neue kinder da und es gibt
immer viele herausforderungen und da hat
einfach mein herz dafür höher geschlagen
aber ich stehe mittlerweile nicht nur
für schulklassen sondern eben auch vor
der kamera für euch das heißt ich habe
auch mein hobby nämlich das kochen und
backen einfach auch zum beruf gemacht
und eben angefangen diese videos zu
drehen
jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht wie so
erzähle ich euch das jetzt es gibt
wahrscheinlich ganz viele unter euch die
vielleicht noch gar keine ausbildung
haben oder nicht studiert haben noch
keinen beruf gelernt haben
vielleicht seid ihr aber auch schon in
den beruf oder in der ausbildung oder in
einem studium uns hat vielleicht gar
nicht so glücklich darüber
weil ihr euch eventuell vorher nicht
über den beruf eben erkundigt habe den
ihr gerade lernt und ich würde euch
jetzt vorschlagen wenn ihr aus meiner
region kommt also aus dem bereich
karlsruhe
dann könnt ihr jetzt am samstag das ist
der 24 januar zwischen 10 und 15 30 auf
eine messe kommen in karlsruhe
und zwar ist es die einstieg beruf und
die wässer wird einfach veranstaltet von
der ihk von der agentur für arbeit und
von der handelskammer karlsruhe und dort
werden einfach über 260 aussteller seien
aus unternehmen aus schulen usw
und die stellen einfach ihre berufe vor
das heißt ihr könnt dann dahingehend der
eintritt ist kostenlos
dann könnt ihr euch einfach alle
berufsfelder anschauen egal wie alt ihr
seid ob jetzt eine ausbildung machen
wollen oder ein duales studium
es ist egal was er könnte einfach
hingehen und ich werde da auch dort sein
das heißt ihr könnt dann auch mich
kennenlernen
entwickeln uns auch bisschen austauschen
und uns bisschen unterhalten und was ich
ganz toll finde da gibt es dann also da
kann man auch ein praktikumsplatz suchen
das heißt man muss jetzt nicht hin und
sofort einen ausbildungsplatz finden
sondern ihr könnt einfach mal auch
verschiedene praktika machen und euch
einfach mal über berufe erkundigen weil
ich finde nichts ist schlimmer wenn man
in dem beruf steckt dem eigentlich gar
nicht machen will
denn ihr müsst ihr überlegen das wollte
ja das ganze leben lang machen und
deswegen sollte es ja auch im beruf
seien dauer zu euch passt und dort auf
der messe gibt es daneben auch so ein
kleines spiel und zwar vielleicht seid
ihr noch zu jung dafür aber früher gab
es mal die sendung herzblatt das war
dann so dahm sich kandidaten beworben
und die kandidatin zum beispiel hat dann
nur anhand vom hören sich für jemanden
entschieden und so wird es dort auch
sein da gibt es dann ich glaube um 11
uhr und um 13 uhr
ebenso aus wie seine sendung da könnt
ihr dann hingehen und hab ich euch
mündlich bewerben für eine
praktikumsstelle und dann wird nur
anhand von eurer stimme und von dem was
ihr gesagt habt entschieden weil die
praktikums stelle bekommt und ich finde
es einfach richtig toll
ich meine klar sind leute die jetzt
einen auszubildenden suchen
professionell und ziemlich objektiv aber
da hat man einfach gar keine vorurteile
weiß nicht wie ihr ausseht man weiß
nicht woher er kommt es kommt wirklich
nur auf eure stimme und auf das gesagte
darauf an das finde ich einfach richtig
toll und ich werde jetzt in nächster
zeit gemeinsam mit der ihk in karlsruhe
ein paar berufe entdecken und einfach
für euch vorstellen das mache ich denn
hier als video
ich finde es nämlich immer ganz wichtig
meine youtube plattform mit dieser
reichweite die ich mittlerweile hab
nicht einfach nur für kochen back videos
zu nutzen was zwar auch sehr sinnvoll
ist aber ich möchte auch gern immer
etwas mehr machen und das nutze ich
jetzt so als chance um euch so ein stück
weiter zu helfen euch einfach in einen
beruf zu finden und ich würde mich total
freuen wenn ihr da vorbeikommt
wie gesagt bin ich auch da zwischen 10
und 15 und 30 findet das ganze stadt
das ist in der messe karlsruhe in der dm
arena und der eintritt ist kostenlos
habe ich schon gesagt da kommt man mit
dem auto hin aber auch mit öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln
ganz wichtig finde ich es auch wenn er
zum beispiel eure eltern mitbringt weil
die eltern haben ja auch so ein bisschen
mitspracherecht
oder kennen oder kennen euch zumindest
und können euch da wahrscheinlich auch
bei der entscheidungshilfe alles ein
bisschen unterstützen und wir leben hier
in der karlsruher umgebung echten purem
luxus den über 20 prozent der freien
ausbildungsstellen sind einfach gar
nicht gesetzt und das heißt die firma
die schulen die unternehmen die wollen
euch deswegen müsst ihr einfach hingehen
und euch vorstellen und ich denke viele
von euch werden dort ihren traumberuf
finden ihre traum ausbildung und duales
studium egal was geht da auf jeden fall
hin
ich freue mich wenn ihr kommt und ich
denke dass es eine richtig gute sache
ist vor allen dingen für jung und alt
und alle die eben nicht genau wissen was
sie machen wollen oder einfach ihren
beruf auch ändern wollen
samira was willst du eigentlich man
werden wenn du groß bist grundform
prinzessin okay das berufsfeld gibst du
nicht aber bis sarkastisch gibt es
wahrscheinlich auch als ich freue mich
wenn ihr am samstag vorbei kommt ich bin
auch da und ich freue mich echt schon
euch alle kennen zu lernen
ihr könnt natürlich auch herkommen wenn
ihr von weiter weg seid das geht
natürlich auch bis samstag 10